discours était très solennelle le chef
de l'état s'est exprimé pendant environ
15 minutes un peu moins que les années
précédentes mais il est vrai que le
discours était particulièrement solennel
il a commencé par remercier les français
pour leur responsabilité et leur civisme
durant cette pandémie le discours a
poursuivi en disant qu'il fallait
désormais travailler autrement renoncer
à certaines activités pour les français
dans l'année à venir il a évoqué les
différents de z que l'état avait apporté
aux citoyens s'ils avaient été mises en
place par l'état des investissements
historiques selon lui pour la santé
également qu'ils porteront selon louis
leurs fruits dans les années à venir
notre pays est celui qui est le plus
intervenu fin de citation il a également
ensuite évoqué brièvement le break site
en évoquant le fait que le royaume uni
reste notre voisin notre ami est notre
allié notre destin est d'abord en europe
notre souveraineté nationale passe par
une europe plus forte également voilà un
discours qui a évoqué le break site le
plan de relance unique et massif qui a
été instaurée par la france à la demande
de la france et l'allemagne avec une
transition écologique et numérique 2020
ne se résume pas à la pandémie
fin de citation et ensuite eh bien vous
l'avez entendu cette longue énumération
lors de laquelle il a évoqué les vies de
français ordinaire le personnel soignant
les chauffeurs entrepreneurs jeunes
écoliers libraire enseignants sportif et
puis morissette cette première femme
française avoir été vaccinées dans un
ehpad de sevran il a évoqué une forme de
courage qui compterait les différents
complotisme a évoqué manuel macron ces
visages et c est cette personne sont
ceux de l'espérance pour les années à
venir
générosité inventivité en 2021 nous
saurons faire face les premiers mois de
l'année seront difficiles mais nous
relèverons les défis à venir
la laïcité la fraternité la sécurité et
le travail doivent nous permettre de
tenir et je ne laisserai pas une lenteur
s'installer en ce qui concerne le
processus de vaccination et comme vous
l'avez entendu avec notre invité
précédent et bien certaines voix
commencent à s'élever
quant à 7 cette vision du président vu
qu'en france il ya pour l'instant très
peu de vaccination contre contrairement
à nos voisins européens mais ensemble
regardons l'avenir et la renaissance
européenne vient
un responsable voilà ce qu'on peut
retenir globalement de ce discours du
président qui a été plus que solennelle
cette année